sta andando a tutti i ragazzi nuova
challenge con la route un po diversa dal
solito perché abbiamo varie pendenze
nella ruota e dovremmo fare una
challenge di disegno che non
approfondire gli stessi temi stime
ricordati abbiamo già fatto una
challenge di disegni ultimi 20 secondi
dobbiamo disegnare una cosa che ci
riceva un app del telefono mi è piaciuta
tantissimo a fattori denunciato anche
dove ci siamo divertiti troppo quindi
abbiamo deciso di farne un'altra questa
volta a fare molto più complicato perché
della loro organo a sud di bari
penitenze ad esempio disegnare bendato
disegnare con la bocca a disegnare con
la mano sinistra come assurde come
sempre dal telefono c'è un sito dice
cosa potremo disegnare poi gireremo la
ruota vedremo come dovremmo dire
per voi nei commenti per ogni turno
dovrete votare se ho vinto io o se ha
vinto vitale questa volta non dovrete
votare alla fine del video ma per ogni
turno perché ovviamente i disegni
saranno diverse ogni turno eliminando
state attenti a ogni disegno mettetevi
comodi prendete i pop corn ovidio a
tutto schermo lasciato in bollente se
volete vedere altre challenge di disegno
e iniziamo subito allora primato sul
sito genero l'idea allora dobbiamo
ridisegnare una lumaca gigante che tiene
un bambino e falsini vista come allora 0
la rosa vediamo come deve disegnarla
girate tutte
ora dobbiamo fare
e arriverà a vedere
[Musica]
dai normale quindi vitali dovrà
disegnare con la mansi strano non siamo
mancini
io invece io dovessi segnare con due
mani c'è devo ottenere le due mani così
32 propria mi dicono che devi svegliare
non riesco a tenere il foglio addio
tutta storta per i figli a doverne
entrate successo perché i orari verità
io rido quando uno finisce prima bisogna
contare fino a dieci e poi il tempo
esaurito dell'altra persona va bene ora
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
[Risate]
allora ecco il mio disegno di vedere il
tuo
vabbè dai l'hai fatto con la stilista
che sta strizzando un bambino allora i
notate che ha vinto il primo turno io ho
vita
questo l'italia estremamente li abbiamo
fatti molto simili non so se hai copiato
io sono questo allora una donna una
vecchietta che gioca a golf
allora tiro la rotta vedevo come
pubblicare di aiuto allora compie
l'altro quindi devo copiare quello più
fame tale fonte con due mani ormai
quindi bene il trio devi tenerlo così
ok allora io devo copiarti prendo il cio
che convengono e non fanno vivere il
braccio io allora non è un alieno di
giocare colf e quella vecchietta a
faccia di evitare quanto accoglierà un
altro grazie si tiene conto con due
maria mazza da baseball
comunque si capisce proprio una
vecchietta soprattutto il fatto che non
abbia la faccia dei cappelli ok ora io
ho pianto quello che posso che stare
zitti orribile
guardate ha fatto un alieno che gioca
col maschiaccia perché ci hai capelli
lunghi e il rossetto ma claudia vecchi è
tutto i capelli lunghi e rosmarina di
rocchetta chi inizia a questo
difficilissimo dobbiamo fare una scimmia
che fa pattinaggio in un lago ghiacciato
ma basta che sia un capolavoro
[Musica]
con la mano sinistra lo momenti che
fortunamente un caffè invece con la
penna frantini età mi sto preparando i
colori sinistra da via non mi ricordo
come te l'ha fatta il freebie alzano le
orecchie tonde mi sembra uno che
sicuramente non sembrerà una scimmietta
no sembra provarci come sono fare se mi
ricordo e la coda lunga e rotolata così
sembra una scimmia no visto dando indie
eye fi ga fato vediamo
tu sei bisognerebbe mai fatto così e non
so se che cari ha fatto sì che le
orecchiette donne non faccia mai fatto
molto bene si vede che una scimmia
larghissima del po come vedere la
sfilata che corre ma ora più un orsetto
per il terzo round anita orbitale allora
round numero 4 e dobbiamo disegnare una
formica in palestra e marelli e vivaddio
tu
[Musica]
prendete voto della base di olio di
vedere cosa combinerà vita ultimo
segnale anche formica non mi ricordo
sì mi ricordo come restante la formica
sta riuscendo dopo la fallimentare
ecco il mio caso di evitare quello di
interesse ma cosa devo spiegare una
formica e fa sollevamento pesi con due
bilancieri ma fini ha così tante zampe è
perché la fabbrica hanno 80 zampe ei
suoi bronchi nola formiche hanno tante
zampe a volte nei commenti quante zampe
alla formica la tendenza questa facendo
sollevamento pesi con le altre pensiero
di bellina adesso dobbiamo incorniciarlo
che con il allora ritratti caramia i
pesi qua questa società più l'anno anche
se sembra tipo un tappeto volante o
allora postate chi vince il quarto round
anita o vitale
solo quinto round dobbiamo disegnare un
canguro alla sua festa di compleanno
oddio caduti sono difficili da disegnare
vado io che cosa sia fuori da piazzale
insieme non lo so questo quinto e
razzista non di altro allora pronto
aspetta che devo ricordare all'oro nero
con uno spazio che proverei a cambiare
colore che vogliono pd corre come batte
il cancro ma io non so dove fare gli
occhi vabbè facciamo la corsa da tasca
con il figlio qua quest'uomo tito tutte
le idee adesso non so cosa poco al testo
di confermarmi stiamo ma che regala
qualche sterili e il pacchetto giocavo
al 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 0
[Applauso]
[Risate]
ancora un errore guardate un po altino
si capisce qualcosa dai spiega il tuo
dei camion questo è il regalo di
compleanno unasca un una scatola di un
regalo in una scatola con il sacchetto
sopra caspita per questo al tamburo con
la coda lunga e la zampa per queste sono
le braccia del canguro uguale paese e
quella quale quello rosso questa è una
stella per lavorazione e quel meno
modella sono tutti i coriandoli e stelle
filanti stelle fila che volano in aria
la stella filante più di questa è la mia
rappresentazione del coni del suo
compleanno
il coni ha dimenticato questo qua e il
canguro e questo è un palloncino regalo
questo è un altro palloncino stranamente
questa è l'unica cosa che è uscita una
dritta fatto era diviso nel sito qua c'è
la torta con le candeline che stanno
volando in aria e tufo grigio esistono
delle stelline
ma cosa più bella è la torta con le
candeline che sembrano degli asparagi e
votate chi ha vinto
[Musica]
a disegnare una tartaruga gigante che
corre sul tapis roulant
beh allora vado io
[Musica]
più che tartaruga sembra divisa ue non
vedo l'ora di vedere il the wall poi
pure io non vedo l'ora di vedere il mio
no al contrario stanno dicendo abbiamo
quasi finita e ho finito
ok pronti non so modificato dai spiega
come non si capisce questo marrone a
svitare con register.it è stata allora
questo marrone qui è il guscio si vede
braccina quindi il corpo sta dentro il
commesso questa è la verità è che questi
segni qua sono perché si impastano
si incazza mentre quello verde queste
verdi sono le zampe la coda per la testa
perché il tapis roulant e una seriana
insolita per un anno e questa arancione
equa da far vedere le cose sembra il
tapis roulant batman sisters e poi
questi qua sembra che sia fresco il
pokémon gente non inaugurata or two
baciava con pastore che implora
innestati in olanda e mappe sembra uno
scoiattolo che ha rubato la merenda camp
nou il corso mi sembra un sacco pieno di
uno scoiattolo che ha scontato dal fare
un picnic sotto un albero
[Risate]
questa la tartaruga deve essere gigante
sul tapis roulant di un albero lane più
grande talento ma guarda che goccia che
ho fatto io che è enorme ed di rula
nella metà del gusto la mia perché la
tartaruga è proprio bulbo al town che
cosa però se cosa c'è uno scoiattolo con
un sacco lo scoiattolo sta andando a
fare un picnic scappata preso un altro
allora che torna numero ten severità o
vizi vitale e passiamo al settimo turno
numero 7 questo è difficile dobbiamo
disegnare un mostro verde con 5 occhi
che si nasconde corridoio buio
oddio
[Musica]
quando però vedere come mai adesso mamma
portogallo tira un uomo che gli è
capitato libera è qui può farla come
tutta colpa o piazza che devo disegnare
con la bocca stati due uno via
divertendo tantissimo una villa un
bisogno e non riesce a parlare più di
tanto
arriva invece che sto divertendo un
sacco fare questo vostro bellissimo
questo andando bellissimo che sta
emergendo in corridoio buio un sacco per
questo il mio disegno più bello che
bello di segnare così liberamente
esprimere tutta la creatività perché di
fatto shrek
devo dire che è molto carino fatto molto
bene anche se non fa paura come l'ho
fatto da quando atene a quelle orecchie
da coniglio i denti affilatissimi 5
occhi che guardano un po a destra un
possibile
guarda questo invece questa sigla voi
avreste più paura si vede tenuto ridare
a questo cosa super deforme che non si
capisce cos'è oppure questo perché
mostriciattolo tenero e sorridere stata
dice il settimo turno umanità o vitale
moroto attenzione questo divertentissimo
dobbiamo disegnare un corpo che si fa la
manicure o no
[Applauso]
vitale nuovamente con i pennelli colori
e olic altro che un'opera le alte per
vitale io invece con due mani e penso
che però i pennarelli perché ti spazi da
lui domani devo fare allora possiamo il
corvo oddio mi accorgo sembra gabbiano
ma no nome non mi dimenticata che tra
manicure e deve essere fatta nemmeno
nelle zampe posteriori perché ovviamente
quelle superiori sono certo le ali
comunque queste idee sono troppo come
standard a non direi abbastanza bene
sono soddisfatto di lavoro per una
manicure e chi se la deve fare l'ho
fatto solo a si ha una estetista si
all'estetista essi cio che orrore
non si capisce niente ma che questo ti
voglio rubare le zampe va bene si spia
per tu sei a mano libera beato te che io
ho capito io
oddio attacco di un furto spirito giusto
la pec eccolo questo e becco spino
allora questo qui è il corpo vedi qui
c'è l'ala questo è il corpo che scende
la dea il becco con l'altra ala qui
tiene in mano allora qui con l'alcol con
una la tiene in mano la boccetta del
ciclismo altro entra con questa il
pennello nello smalto questa i piedi di
sotto se eletto a fatti reali a quelli
che stanno giù per terra le ha già fatte
e qui si sta mettendo uno smalto i piedi
perché si sa che cordiano i piedi zanca
cosa hai fatto pagare si toccano mozilla
è troppo grande perché gli sta facendo
benissimo e questo inestetismo manicure
e questo è però si è troppo grande
gigante dito devo dire che è molto
carina che opera da d'arte altro che vai
questo è l'ultimo turno quindi dobbiamo
cercare di farlo il più bello possibile
e il tema è una lumaca però quello senza
guscio quindi siamo quasi al che affolla
98 la colla di inconscio quindi con una
roma così nella bagarre ragusa che beve
il tè
[Musica]
con i corsi libero muovere per cui
decente anche i migranti e capelli
fastelli una lumaca che beve il tè a
questo è l'ultimo quindi dobbiamo
impegnarci a questo forse sarà il
migliore che ho fatto sono quasi che fai
ma non facili elena ricci e alterne
allora io ho finito praticamente io la
tua
[Applauso]
cosa ci siamo superati da un po a tutti
adesso per karina nonostante tutto
sembra più un buchetto la tua tutta
vernò normale caccia alle antenne tutto
rischiosa nonni non bene fa ti ho messo
verde no sono un po marrone programmi
hanno fatto e fanno male che li ed al
futuro e quindi è verde ancora che ciò
che bolle in mano o no questo è la tazza
con il the very febbraio sarà gino rea e
questo è il vapore dall idea perché è
caldo che il fumo è sola tazza di chi ha
fatto il fumo ma sembrano i baffi
praticamente fatti una lumaca femminile
ho fatto anche il rossetto del signa ed
è comodamente come se fosse che poi è
comodamente sdraiato sul divano e sto
bevendo il tè nero fatto invece per
terra vedete ho fatto io stavo limitando
da terra sia spostato vola in aria è una
facile con due mani allora per il nono
turno se vinco io o se vince il vitale
con atene come di un like
se volete che facciamo un'altra cialente
di disegno come questa considerate
sicure cosa mettere nella ruota
mi dispiace che non mi è mai capitato di
farlo dipingendo con i colori a1 l'uomo
acrilici e la prossima voglio summit era
stato
fateci sapere qual è stato il vostro
disegno preferito di vitale qual è stato
il vostro film preferito mio e ora mi
lascia un po a quattro ballerine super
cliccare per vedere le nostre altre
challenge non siano i video divertenti a
schiera e cliccate su quella che
preferite
ciao